you know this guy William Shakespeare
he's widely regarded that the greatest
writer in the English language his fever
is heretic Margo
hi Steve what do they both have in
common
let me explain so what is falconry
Volker is defined as the art of using a
trained bird of prey flying at quarry is
essentially sketching your dinner using
a bird of prey it's been around for
thousands of years and it was so popular
back in the 16th century that
Shakespeare started using in his
literature he was such a prolific
falconer that everyone started using his
phrases so much so these expressions are
ingrained in the English language today
like set up when Marlowe has been out
hunting what happens is she will eat
until she gets to a point where
literally she is fed up to here since
full she doesn't want to do anything so
she sit still looks miserable and
therefore we say to people like the kids
look at you sitting there looking said
up
all birds but thousand give years always
one these two little gestures these
leather straps attached to each leg and
when we hold on to her we put them under
the thumb and through the fingers
therefore we have restraint therefore we
can hold him back just like an errant
husband or you go to bear in mind is if
something's being around for so long
it's bound to have an impact on of a
masculine the fault can generally wears
the hood because a very highly strong
very nervous and the hood is a calming
down device and what we do is when we
put the hood on it we're actually
fooling him into thinking it's gone dark
so you've tricked him I would reach him
using a hood to think it's night time so
he relaxes as well as holding these
leather straps the dresses the leash
fashions on to the glove and then we
wrap it around the fingers like a belt
embraces it's an extra precaution in
case you lose the bird how good comes
from an old bird that is learned to hunt
you trapper once you've learned to hunt
therefore she's a better hunter because
she's learnt on her own which is where
we get the word an old hag from now and
how many people have used that everyday
and don't realize it's actually a
falteringly expression so there we had
it thanks Shakespeare
Oh